let's talk about Al Franken after it was
revealed that Trump Attorney General
Jeff Sessions misled Congress and the
public about his meetings with Russian
ambassador's Sergei kids react during
the Trump campaign senator Al Franken of
Minnesota who was on the receiving end
of some of those lives during Jeff
Sessions his confirmation hearing said
hey listen let's be cautious before we
start calling it perjury before we call
for resignation let's be cautious until
we know more
Al Franken now knows more and says he
believes indeed Attorney General Jeff
Sessions committed perjury during his
confirmation hearing when he did not
disclose meetings with a Russian
ambassador which we now know to place at
minimum - apparently three times here is
a reminder of that exchange between
Franken and sessions during the
confirmation hearing well it's obviously
extremely serious and if there is any
evidence that anyone affiliated with the
Trump campaign communicated with the
Russian government in the course of this
campaign what will you do
senator Franken I'm not aware of any of
those activities I have been called a
surrogate at a time or two in that
campaign and I did not have
communications with the Russians um and
I'm unable to comment on right well now
based on a supposedly clarifying
statement from Jeff Sessions senator Al
Franken is ready to say I believe that
he did commit perjury here's Al Franken
on CNN yesterday more accurately
sessions yesterday amended his remarks
to the committee saying that his answer
was correct and that he quote did not
mention communications he had with the
Russian ambassador over the years
because the question did not ask about
them what's your response sir
that's the ridiculous response it's not
a clarification at all of course
the question didn't ask about the
Russian ambassador I didn't ask him he
answered a question that he asked
himself which is did I meet with any
Russians and he answered it falsely he
said no I hadn't so this response I
listened I've been cutting him a lot of
slack I've been refusing to say
that he lied of them I've wanted to wait
for this letter to come out it's hard to
come to any other conclusion right that
he that he just of perjured himself do
you think he perjured himself what do
you think the penalty should be do you
think he should resign I think he should
come before the committee and explain
them this is actually really important
Franken was giving him the benefit of
the doubt he showed restraint
he now has more information and the
information led him to say I believe
Jeff Sessions perjured himself sessions
had a chance to clarify and instead
decided to double down and as I
mentioned earlier it appears that even
the original revelation about their
having been to meetings is false it now
appears as though there were actually
three meetings it's just so tough Pat
for Jeff Sessions to remember any of
this what was discussed which which
meeting it's all just so confusing to
Jeff yeah it was very strange for Jeff
sessions to just bring up this point
when he wasn't even asked about it
usually lawyers choose their words
carefully and don't self-incriminate yet
Jeff sessions you're going to be the top
lawyer in the country made that mistake
a complete unforced error because
Franken didn't ask him the question that
he answered he volunteered the question
was what would you do if you found out
that some Trump people had connections
or meetings with Russia and he said I
didn't meet with anybody he chose to
volunteer that but in writing Patrick
Leahy did ask him if he had any
connections to the Russian campaign if
you had any contact with them and he
just said in a two letter answer no yeah
that was there was no ambiguity there
and I mean whoa whoa whoa let's not get
ahead of ourselves though Pat I mean yes
sessions met with Russian officials
three to three times and yes he did
mislead Congress about the matter and
yes he was under oath while testifying
but a gentlemen of sessions of social
status would never commit perjury any
allegation is just fake news and
unjustified yeah right we'll see what
comes of it